JOE SIENKIEWICZ: So I
started out 28 years ago.
Just imagine, forecast
information came in the form
of paper, piles of paper.
It limited the
amount of information
that we could look at.
We see things now in the
models that we're actually,
in some ways, learning,
and confirming
using other information,
observation satellite data.
So things have changed
enormously in my career.
NARRATOR: Today forecasters
can rely on a vast array
of weather sensors
on the ground,
at sea, in the air,
and even space.
This information is
fed into computer
models that build on
our deep knowledge
of environmental physics.
WILLIAM LAPENTA: The atmosphere
is basically a fluid,
just like water, fish tank.
And fluids are defined
by mathematical equations
in terms of their
structure and how
they would evolve with time.
So we go for the major
terms in an equation,
and then we put them
into a computer model.
And we try to get a solution of
how the atmosphere will evolve.
NARRATOR: Dr. William Lapenta
is the director of NOAA's nine
weather prediction centers.
When a tornado is forming
or a hurricane is brewing,
the accuracy of his models can
be a matter of life and death.
But because there are so many
variables in the atmosphere,
no model spits out the
right prediction every time.
NOAA compensates by running
their models dozens of times,
introducing random
variations in the data.
The result is a cluster
of possible futures
called an ensemble.
WILLIAM LAPENTA: So let's
just say that my putt
was a hurricane track.
OK?
So I put once.
You see the ball roll and you
see it roll a certain way.
OK.
That's one piece of information.
So an ensemble means you would
do that many times over, maybe
20 times, maybe 40 times.
And the thing is, every time
you put it down and stroke
it, something changes.
So then if the
trajectories of the balls
are very close to each other,
that means you either have
a very good model, or there's a
high level of predictability in
that hurricane track, or both.
These are called
spaghetti plots.
And it's essentially just
deterministic guidance overlaid
with a bunch of
ensemble guidance.
So you can really see a lot
of information on one screen.
When they're closer together,
you know you have higher
confidence in your forecast.
There's more certainty
in your forecast.
And then as you go out in time,
solutions begin to diverge.
We become more uncertain
about the forecast.
And really just the
slightest difference can make
a huge change in the forecast.